So let's see if we can figure out what
the directory will be doing in a MOESI
protocol if we have 4 cores
numbered 0 through 3 and
if a directory slice for
location A is in slice 0.
If what happens is this, core 0 reads A,
core 0 writes A, core 1 reads A.
Core 2 reads A, core 3 reads A,
and then core 0 writes A again.
The question for you is in this
sequence of accesses, assuming
that A's not in any of the caches
at the beginning of this, how many
requests are sent by these caches to the
directory only counting the requests?
Then the directory forwards these
requests through how many messages?
Note that it need not be
the same number here.
As a result of sending these, the
directory gets how many responses and
replies?
And finally, how many responses
does the directory send itself?
Again, the protocol is MOESI for
this course, and
we have a directory
protocol with 4 cores.